Now, there's actually another property of sound that we haven't talked about.
And that property is called timbre. So, let me give you an example of this. I'm
going to play a couple of sounds for you. So, first little to this.
[SOUND].
And now, listen to this. [SOUND].
Could you tell the difference?
>> Yeah, One was a guitar and one was a piano.
>> Now, there's interesting that you could distinguish because they both had the
exact same pitch. And they had the same volume. So, this difference between the
sounds is what's called timbre.
>> So, this is basically the difference in the quality of the sound.
>> Yeah, you could think of it like that. Which sort of leads to the next
question.
>> Is that what property the sound wave makes as perceived timbre?
>> Right. And it's the wave's complexity.
>> That's the property of the sound wave that let's us perceive timbre. And what I
mean by that is like this like this, this is what we would call a pure wave.
[SOUND].
But some waves are complex, like this one.
And it's this complexity that allows us to perceive a wave's timbre.
>> Okay, I think this makes sense, but it's a lot of information, let me make sure
I understand.